à chaque printemps depuis 2004 dès que
les beaux jours arrivent elle est de
retour à la Guinguette de tour-sur-loire
reprend du service la saison 2023 vient
d'être lancée à 17h sur place on
retrouve Léa Turquie pour faire un petit
point fréquentation je crois Léa
oui c'est ça tout à fait vous le voyez
dernièrement mais en fait les terrasses
sont complètement remplies pour la tant
attendue réouverture de la Guinguette de
Tours donc le temps est là il fait beau
il fait chaud et tout le monde est
présent en terrasse donc on va aller
voir de plus près comment ça se passe
donc je suis avec Camille donc bonjour
bonjour Alors comment ça se passe
heureux d'être venu à la Guinguette ce
soir ah super heureux le temps et
remarquable pourquoi vous aimez venir à
La Guinguette l'ambiance familiale
conviviale très agréable et vous êtes en
habitués je crois c'est ça
et donc là c'est un plaisir de retrouver
cette Guinga et le plaisir merci
beaucoup en tout cas c'est une bonne
soirée en prévision Carla guinguette
c'est quand même une institution à Tours
l'été dernier c'était plus de 300 000
visiteurs qui sont venus en profiter
cette année elle fête sa 19e édition en
bord de Loire on en parle avec le
co-fondateur et président de
l'association du petit monde Ronan
Briand on l'écoute
les guinguettes le succès c'est tour
c'est un peu la ville pionnière des
guinguettes nouvelles génération la
Guinguette historiquement c'est là où
bourgeois il vient son canailler avec le
peuple en fait et nous on a gardé cette
idée là d'un lieu qui réunit tout le
monde avec des codes des complexés
sincères et beaucoup de rencontres
et on y glisse de l'art
qui va de l'art brut de l'art populaire
à l'ARS avant et c'est ce qui fait
l'alchimie de des émotions collectives
donc la Guinguette c'est aussi quatre
sites différents avec le prince le
principal au pied du Pont Wilson où je
me trouve mais il y a aussi la foudre
chez Dupont et la plage qui ouvriront
tout au long du mois de mai donc c'est
l'occasion de profiter aussi des
concerts proposés sur la scène juste
derrière et ce soir on retrouve corps au
Pétrus swing et afro Jules à partir de
20h donc quant au bar réel alcool c'est
avec modération bien sûr la Guinguette
reste ouverte jusqu'au 30 septembre
merci merci Léa et bonne soirée car
j'imagine que vous allez y rester un
petit peu en dehors de vos heures de
travail j'imagine allez à tout à l'heure
merci beaucoup